tell us what is ultra egos did it oh
well they're kinda this is kind of a
story of e story so I can tell my side
of the story and you can tell you're so
that's where I like to think that much
how it is be a story a I don't think
that's I'm just ruin any story i'm gonna
drive the film okay probably that a
story my side of the story is about
superheroes it exists and they have kind
of captured they've captured all the
supervillains and then of kind of
outstay their welcome in society and so
people of society is kind of kind of
getting tired of them and they're also
very getting tired of spending their tax
money to fund the superheroes so the
government is going to cut their funding
soon so the superheroes have to come up
with a plan to become relevant again so
see through with my character um yeah
and he's fridge and we're kind of like
the lower echelon of the supercorps you
know kind of the the foot soldiers and
so I'm transporting a supervillain to a
new facility and so I've got a scheme
that I'm actually being the head of the
supercorps is making me kind of go
through with this and I have to kind of
trap my best friend see through into
kind of doing this event which I don't
wanna give away but shall I give it away
and that's just the first two minutes of
the movie then after that you're out
about that oh well actually not Morgan
in the movie anymore after that yeah
I've ever met before i'm personally
hours on the yellow a lot of points
most of the time what's in my head is
that while the BB side of the story is
why I'm fridge you know this this
superhero on one hand who's come out to
the Hamptons to deal with this this plot
that seats was kind of hatched to to get
our funding back and at the same time
I'm dealing with a personal crisis which
is that my alter ego of my real self
Brendan who's just a young human
civilian guy is having girlfriend
problems and I decide that I'm going to
dress up and hit on my own girlfriend as
fridge and and she starts having an
affair with me so I'm cheating on myself
with myself and I'm having a bit of a
crisis about that not knowing who she
really likes more whether it's the real
me but who is the real me is that the
guy in the blue tights who can shoot i
SAT his hands or is it the the normal
little comic sketching dweeb who lives
with his girlfriend and then as the
movie sort of goes on all these things
you know see through his crazy plot to
my personal crisis kind of intertwining
cause shenanigans and what other types
of the superpowers jihad besides the
shooting of ice it's only have one
superpower I don't know if you know this
that's why we work together yeah and
they're pretty they're kind of realistic
so he can shoot ice and my character can
simply see through things it's a head
see through me going just we can read
lips pretty well yeah but that's more of
an acquired skill yeah
necessarily like a suit and I can read
really fast but that's also something
that I not really fat like not faster
than the average person but I can rock
and read pretty quickly but that was
also not never that's enough a on
me though that was just something that
you got something I had on your that
didn't make it into no one talked about
that correct yeah I don't know with
never brought up in the film does he
move his lips what do you mean sorry is
he actually so skilled and he doesn't
notice I don't know I need to get a
mirror I always thought of your
character is illiterate and I think it
kind hello lay off that way in what did
I say I said I did really fast maybe it
maybe it's that I mean literally maybe
that's all my other also that could be
my other my other superpower is is is
illiteracy illiteracy fighting
illiteracy with illiteracy exactly I'm
gonna do we write that down as I know
there's a t-shirt idea maybe writing and
literacy with illiteracy Joey currents
kid project cars kids can't read current
kids can't quite read okay okay see
through I read its gothic a creep
remember those x-ray glasses is asking
yeah it's part of his thing or no he can
miss more of his totally unnecessary
that's something he just would bright
bring a said every day please go
anywhere those yellow glasses if you
just sneak a month oops is the camera
rolling no we needed something because
he had the mask and so you needed we
needed something to kind of say okay
this guy's incognito because but you
never see you don't really see my
character is you see him outside of this
costume but just at the beginning in the
end of the film so we needed something
to when he's in public you know he but
it became kind of a nuisance because the
camera would always reflect on them on
the plastic of the god of a dog yeah
crystal ever saw at the DP he really
hated those glasses and it's tough for
me too because I would have to kind of
tilt my head is it okay I can't see the
camera now and I would have to do the
scene without moving my head too much so
that the reflection of the I have
amazing stillness a lot of people have
asked me it is Joey playing a role
in this movie with a pizza with the
tilted head issue and I had to explain
to them no no you are not a robot in
this film I feel like I look really
natural and I do it yeah a little bit
robotic robotic act natural yeah
sometimes people start messing with it
because they think the spring is present
in the stillness of man God just a very
odd thing that you have to do very well
one thing a story you know I mean you
really get around the film I put that
ground of it next question
you